Hi Guys.
Today I'm going to talk about this book,
teach yourself Arabic and I'm going to
tell you whether it is a genius work of
art or a piece of crap from hell.
Okay,
good afternoon guys.
I'm going to talk today about a book and
CD program that I used in the past to
study Arabic.
Uh,
it's called teach yourself Arabic from
the infamous teach yourself series a in
it's this book right here by Jack smarts
and Francis El Toro for or something
like that.
I don't know how to say his last name,
first of all.
That's a,
I should say upfront.
I want to be careful that we're talking
about the same book.
There are actually two books called
teach yourself Arabic.
This one right here is the old one from
1991.
This one is basically focused on,
uh,
on receptive skills on reading and
listening to Arabic.
It's not really focused on
conversational or communicative Arabic.
That one is kind of universally
lambasted by people who buy it because
when they buy a teacher yourself booked,
they're hoping to learn to communicate.
Most people,
I think.
And that book is basically based on um,
reading and listening to the news in
Arabic.
That's really the purpose of that book.
So we're gonna focus on this one,
which is the new one published in 2001
and it has a much more community
communicative,
conversational focus and it's much more
suitable for the average learner who
buys teach yourself.
So we'll talk about this.
It's a pretty good book but it has some
weaknesses.
So I want to talk about those just to
give you an idea and that will help you
maybe use the book better.
So first of all,
the book is based on,
well it's teaching you modern standard
Arabic.
That is the formal kind of Arabic,
the standard Arabic that is used in
newspapers.
It's used in the media and it's used
kind of as a tool to to communicate
across dialects because Arabic has a lot
of different dialects.
So when people want to communicate with
a speaker of another dialect,
they kind of,
they incorporate some of the standard
language into their speech to make it
understandable for the other person.
So this is,
this is all about modern standard
Arabic,
but it teaches it in a way that is
communicative,
conversational and helps you to interact
in daily situations.
So that's kind of rare.
There are some other books now that,
that do the same thing,
but a few years ago this was kind of the
only,
the only popular book like that,
the only common book like that.
And it was kind of rare to find in
modern standard Arabic book that did
that.
Um,
so it's good for that and it's good in
the language that it teaches.
Like if you look at unit one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
those they teach good language that's
useful in daily situations in the
vocabulary of presents I think is
useful,
presented in a logical order.
Um,
it gives you a lot of experience with
different language skills.
So it's not only just the reading and
the listening,
but it gives you a chance to do some
writing exercises and that gives you a
chance to do some grammar exercises.
It's got a good balance of skills,
I find.
Of course you're not speaking with
someone,
you're not.
No one's listening to you and giving you
feedback unless you have a private
teacher.
But it covers all of the bases to
whatever extent a book like this can.
So it is a regular teacher self book
even though it's based on a modern
standard Arabic.
So it's good,
uh,
good in that sense.
The strange thing about this book is
that it switches gears suddenly,
like the first seven units are based on
good conversational situations,
daily life situations.
Then in unit eight it switches gears and
throws you in head first into this
traditional story about Sinbad,
the sailor,
and I think it's actually an authentic
text from a book,
from some old book and it's written in
very kind of archaic Arabic and they
throw you in head first and you're
reading this going,
wait,
I haven't learned this stuff yet.
Why am I reading about Sinbad,
the sailor using these archaic sentence
structures?
So I found that unit quite frustrating
and it made me want to stop using the
book to be honest,
because there were things in that story
that I couldn't find in this book that I
couldn't find them in,
uh,
on the internet and Google as trying to
s to search and find what these
grammatical structures mean,
but it couldn't.
Um,
so I think the idea that they had was to
force you to,
to understand the main meaning without
understanding everything.
But if they do that without explaining
that,
and they do that suddenly,
even though the first seven units were
kind of different than it's a shock to
your system and you're going to get
frustrated.
So I found unit eight was annoying.
Unit nine was similar because they threw
you in to a bunch of advertisements,
like the advertisements from a newspaper
or a magazine.
Uh,
and there were some apartment ads,
like looking for an apartment and the
exercises ask you questions and you have
to answer it based on these
advertisements.
But the advertisements are full of words
that you haven't seen before and it's
just really hard to decipher them.
Uh,
and there's not a lot of guidance or
explanation about the goal of that
exercise.
So if they had said like,
do the goal here is just a scan for
important information,
don't worry about everything,
then maybe it would be easier for
learners to get through and not worry
about the stuff they're missing.
But it doesn't really do that.
It just throws you in,
you confused because you're expected to
deal with all this language you haven't
learned yet.
So that's a weakness of this book cause
that that element,
it's written by two people and I have
the feeling that uh,
units one to seven were written by one
person,
unit eight and nine,
and some of the others were written by
someone else.
That could be true.
I'm not sure.
Um,
later on in the book,
some of the chapters get back to that
communicative focus and that's good.
But some of them are still unclear.
And there were,
there are some sections where you're
thrown in head first without adequate
guidance.
I feel.
Um,
another weakness of the book is that at
some vocabulary appears in the exercises
or in the texts that is not taught.
It's not given to you in the book and
it's not in the glossary at the back of
the book.
So for,
uh,
for,
um,
a new learner who has just bought one of
these books and doesn't have an arsenal
of dictionaries and grammar reference
books and stuff yet that's really
frustrating.
Uh,
it's one of the most frustrating things
to look in the glossary and not find the
word you're looking for,
especially when it appears in this book.
Um,
they're also very simple words.
I tried to look up,
like I remember when I was using this
book,
I remember thinking to myself like
almost every time I went to look up a
word in the glossary,
it wasn't there.
Even when it was a really simple English
word,
I would look it up and it wouldn't be
there.
And I would always be thinking,
why isn't that word in this book?
Why isn't it in the glossary?
That's such a simple,
basic word.
It should be in here.
Um,
so the glossary is not up to snuff,
I think.
Um,
and they should really make sure that
everything we're expected to,
uh,
expected to deal with.
All the words were expected to
understand it should be taught in this
book.
So they don't do that.
To get around that,
you need to have a good dictionary and
to know how to look up words in that
dictionary using the root or whatever
the system is.
So get a dictionary and that will help
you out a lot with this.
So with that said,
it's good.
It's,
it does teach good language and it
teaches good situations and I think,
um,
uh,
it,
it teaches modern standard Arabic in a
way that is useful for you to use as a
communication tool.
So just be prepared for those weaknesses
if you get this book.
Uh,
just that there are some parts that
throw you in head first without a lot of
support.
If you're an inductive learner,
if you're someone who likes to figure
things out without a lot of help,
then you might enjoy that and just
slugged through it and find that fun.
Um,
but if you're a more traditional
deductive learner,
and you like to get the instruction up
front,
and then,
uh,
no,
everything that comes after that,
then this book might frustrate you a
bit,
but it's good.
I'll give it 3.5
stars out of five.
Not the best,
but not the worst.
All right.
Thank you for listening and have a nice,
yeah.